there's been a major shift in the war in
Ukraine Kiev has launched a
counter-offensive along the front lines
to retake territory and Russia has been
getting hit behind its own lines in
Moscow there have been multiple aerial
drone attacks in the Border Town of
Belgrade violent incursions in Crimea an
attack on an oil Depot and throughout
Russia and russian-controlled territory
there have been strikes on refineries
Railways and all kinds of other
infrastructure
as Ukraine launches the
counter-offensive everyone's been
talking about we mapped out some of the
early signs of its strategy and the
obstacles it has to overcome
let's start on the front lines they
stretch for some 600 miles and experts
say Ukraine has begun to strike in
various places to probe for weaknesses
Ukraine has already had some success
with Ukrainian troops raising flags as
they liberate towns in the East but
Russia currently controls some 20
percent of Ukraine's territory shaded in
light red and Ukraine will have to push
through the huge trenches minefields and
ditches that Russia has built to defend
that territory
adding to the challenges much of this
land is flat and open that makes
Ukraine's troops and Equipment
vulnerable to strikes especially since
it doesn't have the support of aircraft
to provide cover plus the destruction of
this Dam in her son flooded a key part
of the battlefield both sides blamed
each other but the destruction could
ultimately hurt Ukraine not only has the
flooding forced thousands of people from
their homes it makes it hard for
Ukrainian troops to cross this river
which ultimately makes it harder for
them to sever the land bridge between
Russia and Crimea and it makes it easier
for Russia to move troops and equipment
to other parts of the front lines now
let's look at the attacks inside Russia
and russian-controlled territory hits on
oil Depots Railways and other
infrastructure are known as shaping
operations they show how Ukraine is
trying to choke Russia's supplies off
while simultaneously attacking the front
lines
thank you
Ukraine staged similar attacks last year
using u.s-made High Mars before retaking
key territory now it's armed with
British Storm Shadow missiles that are
fired from aircraft which allow it to
hit targets even farther away that could
force Russia to push supplies further
from the fighting and complicate its
delivery of food Fuel and ammo to troops
in Belgrade cross-border incursions are
forcing civilians to evacuate and
exposing gaps in Russia's defenses
they've been carried out by Russian
fighters who oppose the Kremlin and have
ties to keys that's LED local officials
to call on Moscow to send reinforcements
moving soldiers away from these front
lines and into Russian territory could
ultimately weaken Russia's defenses and
help Ukraine try to take back some of
its land there have also been drone
attacks in Moscow over the Kremlin and
in wealthy suburbs no one has been
killed but with buildings cordoned off
Windows shattered and drone fragments in
plain view these attacks have shattered
the perception in Russia that the
conflict is playing out in some far away
land officials in Ukraine have denied
being behind them but Russian President
Vladimir Putin has blamed Kiev
education
foreign
these attacks undermine Putin's
narrative that the so-called special
military operation is going as planned
and they've also fueled internal
divisions with the head of the Wagner
paramilitary group lashing out at
Russian defense officials
so how are these attacks being viewed
outside of Russia and Ukraine So Far
Western countries like the US have
continued to funnel Aid to Kiev and if
Ukraine shows that it can use that
equipment effectively they could Supply
even more powerful weapons down the road
but they don't want a broader conflict
we have been very clear with the
ukrainians privately we've certainly
been clear publicly that we do not
support attacks inside Russia and
there's another important country
watching all of this closely China has
signaled that it does not want to see
Russia collapse and presidents she and
Putin remain close so if it looks like
Russia can't stand on its own two feet
experts say Beijing could potentially be
moved to send lethal Aid to Moscow which
would Mark a major new phase of the war
[Music]